so to wrap up our discussion of
hydroxychloroquine and how after a
number of studies showing it's not
helping patients and in fact maybe
hurting
Trump is no longer talking about it Fox
News is barely talking about it both dr.
Phil who is a psychologist not a medical
doctor and dr. oz who is a medical
doctor but is widely known for promoting
quack cures both of them have been
saying anti-science
things about the virus but dr. oz has
been particularly a present as a
promulgator of chloroquine miracle
treatment type nonsense for many weeks
now we now have a study I told you about
from the VA which says this isn't
working well it might be hurting
patients now credit to Fox & Friends
they actually did a story this morning
about that study and they brought on dr.
oz let's take a look all right so let's
move on to hydroxychloroquine they did a
study a limited study at a VA hospital
and they came to the conclusion it did
no benefit and they still had 19 deaths
what's your reaction to that since
you've been doing we've all been doing
heavy work to find out where if this
works or not so I hate to already be
jumping in so quickly but Brian Kilmeade
is already rewriting history Brian
Kilmeade says we've been doing heavy
work to find out if this works or if it
doesn't work no dude you've been
promoting the drug just like Trump has
now that it's not working he's rewriting
history to say we've been investigating
with an open mind maybe it works maybe
it doesn't no that's not what you were
doing you're rewriting history let's now
go to dr. oz well the VA study looked at
older and quite a bit sicker patients
all male patients in their hospitals and
they show that the drug by itself didn't
help it might harm that population is
you know they've been other studies done
this devious they was retrospective they
look back to see what had happened
because they weren't gathering the data
at the time that they were actually
giving the admitted medications studies
that have done this prospectively so
looking forward and giving it as they as
collecting data as they're going along
like in France or the randomized trials
from China have shown benefits but only
really when that's given earlier to
patients so dr. oz mentions all the
reasons we might not be able to trust
this
you study it was only male patients well
that's actually good in in most good
studies you look at only men or only
women to eliminate sex as a possible a
factor that effects the results of the
treatment
it was retrospective well many of the
studies that are being done are but the
most disturbing thing is that dr. oz
mentions that French study the French
study dr. oz mentions as a counterpoint
had under 40 participants and no control
group the VA study at least had close to
a sample size of 400 and again dr. oz
could just tell the truth and stay and
say every study so far has had some
issues but this is a bigger study and it
doesn't look good instead dr. Oz says
well you know you've got this study and
you've also got the French study with
the 36 or the 38 patients with no
control group and he says that one
looked good even if this one doesn't
very dishonest he also mentions studies
from China that looked good I won't even
comment on that now because later in the
segment oz himself says we really need
data from the United States if we need
US data why even bring up the Chinese
study now in this next segment he
actually does say the right thing which
is what I've been saying all along the
fact that matter is we don't know
thankfully these dot these medications
or prescription only so doctors are
desperately awaiting the completion of
the higher-quality randomized trials and
we've covered them on the show several
times in South Dakota University of
Minnesota now has over a thousand
patients randomized there's additional
trials going on let's get that data so
we know what we're dealing with so that
would have been the right thing to say
all along which is we just have to wait
doctor foul she said we need randomized
controlled trials until we have those we
really don't know that's what they
should have been saying from day one a
little bit more here where Brian
Kilmeade introduces the z-pak element
which may actually make the treatment
even more dangerous and dr. oz just
white flags and says we really just
gotta wait for the RCTs and just to
follow up real quick just is it
important to know what they're combining
it with and the dosage because it's not
supposed to be taking on its own don't
you have the z-pak
there's a lot of variables Brian I gotta
say I think at this point there's so
much data coming from so many places we
are better off waiting for the
randomized trials dr. foul she's been
asking for otherwise this and we keep
reacting we'll be back and forth for
studies that show opposite result and a
lot of it might have to do with when you
get the medication if you give it to
people or already having breathing tubes
down their throat it might it's not
gonna have a same kind of effect as if
you give it early but we don't have
randomized data from the United States
to educate us well enough right now
so again if dr. oz had said this on
April 1st I would be praising dr. oz I
would be saying hey you know what when
Trump was promoting it and you had just
this French study to tout even though it
had 38 people in it if then dr. oz said
wow she's right we've just gotta wait I
would I would have respected him from
day one instead dr. oz and Fox and Trump
have all been promoting this and this
would have been the thing to say then
rather than to spend three weeks
promoting it only to now say you know
you really need randomized controlled
trials it's pathetic and with every
passing day hydroxychloroquine is a word
that is harder and harder to find both
coming out of Donald Trump's mouth and
coming out of Fox News broadcasting
really pathetic we've been saying it
from day one and they actually have been
spreading dangerous disinformation all
along we'll have more about this change
in tact when it comes to chloroquine on
the David Pakman show
Instagram page make sure you follow us
on instagram at david pakman show if you
ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinka splink
a-- stakes thousands of popular
non-fiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka blink east has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month and you get the
entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video